so this is Sal Khan here with Emily
abraaj our biology content fellow and
you have a PhD in biology so you know
what you're talking about you'd like to
think that wouldn't you and so what what
are our platonic Academy has had biology
content for a long time now you know
back in the day I think in 2007-2008 I
had made a handful of biology videos but
but what are we hoping to do now I mean
I think here what we're really going for
is having really comprehensive coverage
you know really making sure that we look
at all of the different branches of
biology and have great material that's
going to be a resource for someone who's
looking at any one of those you know not
just certain things that happen to be
cool but really digging into a lot of
different branches of the subject and so
how are you thinking about I mean you're
you're out there trying to figure out
what we should cover and what we
shouldn't cover what is what is your
hope for the next year I mean my hope is
really that we're going to have material
that will serve pretty much anybody
who's in like an advanced high school
level or an intro college level class
and I mean there's a lot of diversity in
those classes so it's not going to match
every class but the hope would be that
if you encounter a topic that you're
confused about or interested in in one
of those classes that you would be able
to come to us and and really learn more
about that and though and the way we've
been working together is fun it's fun to
actually have people to work with now
they never fit into the walk-in closet
but now we have and you know you've been
doing a pretty incredible job you've
been obviously taking a high level of
you thinking about the different gaps
what we need to fill in to really have
exhaustive coverage for intro College
biology class or an AP biology class
you've been writing articles like this
one right over here where it's you know
to really give me a hopefully intuitive
but thoughtful explanation and kind of
deep explanation of what what's going on
you're also we're working together to
produce more videos so that once again
we don't just cover a lot of the main
ideas in biology we're covering all of
the things that you would see in an AP
biology class or a college class so what
what what's what's neck
what are you working on right now right
now i am just sort of in the middle of
genetics and you've already got a lot of
great videos on genetics so i'm kind of
looking at what we already have as well
as sort of some extensions of that like
the sort of the chromosomal basis of
genetics and how that was discovered on
so that's kind of what's on my plate
right now but after that it'll kind of
be a full steam ahead into molecular
biology DNA replication transcription
and translation which again we've we've
already got some great content on but
there are places where I think we can
even build it out some more i'm excited
i know i have a backlog of four or five
videos that you've been asking for for a
few days so don't be coming soon i'm
excited for them thank you